well the one good thing about doing
comedy is you can be around funny
[ __ ] people see laughing when you're
doing a drama a little actors they
they're good at that but they don't have
great senses of humor yeah so then
you're just kind of there and yeah
Eagles and [ __ ] muffins from craft
service and you're just getting [ __ ]
fat yeah I don't get fat ankles no yeah
but you shredded but no no no no you
know me I'm shred you lost a lot of
weight though I did yeah so what's the
deal psoriasis so I mean no bread and
stuff so you get psoriasis if you eat
bread yeah so I have to eat a certain
diet pop you start [ __ ] pops a super
lean no no is it that or is it just that
you don't be careful Milo I mean what
the more and more every when I and I'm
not saying you look a lot like this
person but them every time I see you in
something I'm not
this is I'm not you know like something
it's actually not I know what you're
saying but no but I feel like you're
gonna be insulting I get it and I know I
would feel that way too but this is my
guess so your I know okay I'm a guest of
the fighter in the kit yeah okay don't
be a dick I'm not okay
the every time I see you you look more
like the Cryptkeeper
from and you look a lot like it but it's
more more yeah you know the you know
they told you not to me okay I told you
not to be in self no no so why did you
say that um you know what he put no I'm
saying you know any pops up yeah he's a
skeleton look at everything I look like
that the tells from the Crypt da Queen
duck let's get dangerous sir kwinda you
know browser Rogan Joe Rogan was like
get yourself a 911
Tesla's nice but you got to plug it in
yeah
the world's not ready for it yet so get
yourself and then he was pulling up
different Porsches and that that's
silver one that I don't have to say that
I but the problem is the back seats I
got kids I can't I can't be the guy who
has who stuffs his kids in the back get
it back the kids will all give it yeah I
know yeah although I've Christ sat in
the back exactly yeah you'll figure it
out
great growth you know each other's lap
in the front you see where frankly I
have a challenger yeah
he's eight hundred horsepower yeah it
says boss level on it they made it for
him I was like come on dude it's so loud
row row row
now does that come with trt how does
that work like when you open up the back
is there just vials of testosterone it
comes it with its own you should shoot
you Isles and then there's the syringe
circulating like how's that work yeah
you gotta have to come with clomid and
HGH like how's that I don't know with
those cars yeah it's a little much
it's holy what does it mean to have 800
horsepower what does that mean it means
if you lined up eight hundred horses
that's your car that's so stupid means
if you tried to hang you on the eight
hundred horses that's what it's like
hanging under your car eight hundred of
them my car on the track the system
Frank's it does disrespectful don't be
disrespectful to his car hey Frank cool
ride see me on the tracks bro what well
his cars a muscle car you are there in
the muscle cars are performance cars I
feel like Porsches just up you dick into
tits bro
yeah yeah yeah dicks okay dicks
well the Porsche is the handling and
every I have intrigued now I want to go
test drive a a priest pre-owned that's
what you should do
yeah well I love it'll forces for you
bro look let me talk to some people
Steven kitchen why do you guys only
entitle your episodes with the number
why don't you have an S it's raw and
it's what you get oh Jesus Christ it's
it's pure and this podcast is the truth
you know let's let's go let's talk about
this for a second yeah I I am the best
guess you guys get that's not Fame wise
I get you get for more famous people but
when I come on good dish
okay when I come on baboom all right
okay don't take we're not we're not on a
spacecraft but you know you do fine it's
all good and don't be a dick but my
[ __ ] do I get the most hits on your
podcast I don't know
oh I do Jenny does hey I mean maybe if
you had [ __ ] Ilan have you had like
anybody like Elon Musk but when it comes
to c-listers like me see this does like
me you get massive hit what are you what
level I'm an acapella I'm a mama imma
like at all imma like a Barry you're not
a sec I'm a baritone Shem ba ba ba ba
nobody I don't do duets I really don't I
do solo pretenses no I don't do it I did
see if you're singing I go like this go
like that but when you stop I go
no see you sound like a dog but I sound
like a [ __ ] dog dude I had Leah's
gonna be 40 M down things are gonna die
gonna die uh-huh then hair falls out her
hair so did everyone in my family hope
your dad will just money because the
well is gonna run dry no no I mean yeah
yeah um but I'll be fine
dude hey but wait can't ever forget what
Jose that's what happens with us we get
on bits we get a bit so we keep going
and we forget what we're gonna say but
we always come back yeah or sometimes we
just caught your Invisalign it's either
better a lot better
oh [ __ ] I'm freezing my car they don't
do whitener though do they
no but I piss straight down straight let
me see the bottom yeah it's still kind
of like yeah but it's it's they're not
light I got three more trays I know damn
you gotta width remember that one guy
was in the back way in the back now he's
in the front in the front I know I don't
want to do far front no not yet now he's
sitting the front row missing I just
noticed that I'm uneven
oh well Bubba called Invisalign not a
miracle line middle it's like your teeth
are still like this don't do that don't
like that and oh there's one dip and
that's because this guy UT the show like
this [ __ ] was shorter your teeth still
look like a [ __ ] level on Excitebike
but it's all good bro by the way
speaking of those rides I can't get on
rides Neymar gets sick I know you like
Dramamine I get sick I got on the
[ __ ] twirly thing that twirls that
bells you can't do Toros I guess this is
grown man again do I get sick like in
right away I get sick my kids like whoa
here's a tip and this is science if you
see a a man who's larger on the kids
ride spin yeah and he's just faced for
not getting sick pedophile yeah I saw it
on Fox News okay I know that yep would
you do if a guy looked at you and goes
for
and you're on the street hey chris
d'elia right yeah you [ __ ] bro mmm
you're [ __ ] cuz you were doing
stand-up and you insulted my girl from
the stage I'm gonna kick your [ __ ]
ass what would you say lawyer up up you
threatened a lawsuit I go like this hold
my watch to someone I trust
what yep hold my wish and then you say
you would fight if it happens it happens
what are you gonna do how what are you
gonna throw your hands in the air and
just go uh nah dude mama bro I'm spindly
bro my knees my [ __ ] legs with your
legs there spin so if you take you out
with a thigh kick you take care of the
thigh sir I accept it [ __ ] you know
what I mean
what you turn in Excel with it yeah turn
and accept it burn and accept it and the
back of my thigh because it doesn't hurt
as much as in the [ __ ] light of
myself so you would you automatic you
would you don't present your IT band you
give them your hamstring yeah man and
then you counter oh yeah I grow do I
counter yeah yeah uh I [ __ ] counter
I'll tell you what I'm gonna do okay I'm
gonna take your brother who's a smartass
that sends me texts yeah like open for
me on the road I'm doing stand-up now
[ __ ] like my brother says I he says [ __ ]
like that sometimes just send me a
picture of him smiling I'm gonna smack
him around with an open hand for no
reason I'm gonna bully him push him down
push him into the bushes no dude yeah
I'm gonna get his get his knees all
scraped up dude and you're gonna sit and
watch and all you're gonna do is go
don't know look don't I'm not gonna do
that don't and I'm not gonna listen no
I'm gonna I'm gonna shove your brother
around make him cry and I'm gonna get if
he has money in his pockets Maurice in
his pockets I'm gonna pull out the money
I'm take his keys throws keys somewhere
for no reason
well so I'm gonna bully him no you're
not gonna do you ain't gonna do jack
no dude right that's not true you're
gonna do [ __ ] job dude and ask them
don'tdon't impose them a will honor all
right on my yeah okay dolia sure come up
I'm gonna chest-bump you know mannose
gonna be on your nose you can smell my
breath okay
and I'm gonna go what right no watch no
you're not no you're not you're gonna go
dude right and you're gonna fall on your
brother I'm not keep and weep with him
and you guys gonna clutch each other
mmm cry and then you know what's gonna
happen I'm gonna funnel peel-out know
your car nope and then you're gonna pop
up and you're gonna say that's what
triggered it hey Cryptkeeper Hey I don't
like this ageist humor
I asked Kat if I was what you thought
you cuz you're a good-looking older like
middle age there you go yeah there you
go
we and I'm a young buck dude I am me
young you know what I realize 44 no you
know what I realized I'm young dude
that's what I realized
no I'm like what the [ __ ] why do I have
Benjamin buttons disease no I think I
got to a certain point where all of a
sudden I started walking back house dude
no cuz your face I've decided is you
have you you that you're what you indent
where your eyes are so you have an
hourglass face which to me to mean only
to me I'm not trying to be a dick about
it okay
but if you look at your face in a vacuum
yeah without your personality right
personality and good hair but just the
face structure yeah is revolting no way
you're saying I got a peanut head in the
worst way